Let's go today to our caller from the 7 07
area code, who is calling today from 7 0 7.
Yes. My name's Gabe. I'm calling from Humboldt
County. Hey, Gabe, what's up? OK. So make
sure you could hear me. I can hear. Yeah.
So I'll be real brief. I really appreciate
you taking me on. I live in a rural part of
California and one of our major crops here
is marijuana.
Yes, I know. They get sacked.
I hear I was up there once for a conference
and the conference was in Mboya. It was near
Ukai Kata Arcata. Exactly.
I was up in all of that in Mendocino. Yes.
And yes, I think I'm county. Yeah. We are
country. It was crazy. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah. Well I live in a more
rural part of California. I'll try to be I
got to try to be brief in my questions. So
first of all, Joe Biden does not have a pro-legalization
stance now. My father was a grower. I'm a
second generation American. And I my family's
still deals with immigration issues. So on
that I am extremely anti-Trump, but I'm not.
I'm also anti Biden because he not only doesn't
support the main cash crop for my county,
but he also was in power when I've had family
members being deported. So I'm more so wondering
why I should vote for Biden in terms of what's
the difference, because to me, I'm looking
at it like you got red version of blue version
of the same person. And by voting for Biden,
I'm not only continuing my own family's destruction,
but my country's destruction because it's
a one party system.
Right. Well, let me ask you. I'm curious.
I'm curious if there's any answer for this.
Sorry. Go ahead. Let let me ask you this.
If we think about the future of marijuana
legalization, which we're seeing a lot of
at the state level.
Right. So a lot of what we're seeing, the
next five to seven years of marijuana legalization
will come from the state level, not from the
federal level is my prediction.
Do you believe that we will get more favorable
rulings of cases that are appealed to the
Supreme Court related to cannabis? If Trump
picks a replacement for Ruth Bader Ginsburg
or if Biden picks a replacement for Ruth Bader
Ginsburg, what what what does your heart tell
you on that?
OK. So I'm actually really glad you asked
me this. I thought about this a couple days
ago talking my wife about this. So Trump and
the Republican Party are pro money. And right
now in Humboldt County, there is huge, massive,
multi-million dollar corporations coming here
and spending money there lobbying.
I think that marijuana legalization, even
with Trump in office, is closer than you think.
Now, again, I will never vote for a right
wing death cult. I'm not going to vote for
Trump. The Republican Party, you know, they
want to see my state burned to the ground
and so on. And I just want to tell everyone
here, do not vote for Donald Trump. Don't
do it. But on that same level, it's like the
difference between the left and the right
in this one is minimal because it's like,
OK. Yeah, you may get someone who may not
be favorable towards it, but financially,
they'll let it go. I mean, it's just like,
you know, alcohol prohibition.
You know, I'm sure a lot of people like that.
Let me just legalize alcohol just a little
bit here, because you're you're seeing a lot.
Let me let me. I. So I I don't get it. I don't
either. I think there's no doubt. I think
so.
Hold on. I think there's no doubt that whoever
Biden picks to the Supremes to go to the Supreme
Court would be better on this issue than whoever
Trump picks. I also believe.
Oh, no doubt. I also believe that remember
back during the Obama Biden era. They said
even though weed is illegal federally, we're
not going to send federal agencies into states
that have legalized it. When Trump put in
Jeff Sessions, they did.
But he did, though the Obama administration,
there was many raids by the feds during those
times.
There is no doubt that there were, but they
were dramatically diminished, whereas Trump's
A.G. ran on.
We're going to ramp that back up. So I think
for me, it is it is not gone by events.
Walker. He believes in nothing.
Gabe, thank you for the call. I very much
appreciate it.
And I hope that you make the decision that
is right for you. Let's take a quick break.
Don't hang up if you're holding, because we
will be right back with your calls in a brief
moment